hi we are back playing fran beau again
we just got our cat taken away from us
by it word so let's go find mr midnight
and let's get back to our realm because
that's what we're in the flying machine
for so let's do this
all right
so we picked up a carrot didn't we
thanks it's a wrench
it can be useful oh paper boat
are you edward's other head i like the
hat can we take the hat no we can't
okay so the number one ina
is that like
does that say one in another language i
have
no idea there's weird noises okay
all right what about this
it won't turn on what should i do press
the buttons all the buttons oh
the button made the floor rise like an
elevator
a mechanical arm are you alive
what does this do
needs some energy to wake it up okay so
maybe we can use this on the screws
take them off
ah
and this one
that way
yeah
okay so it needs a battery
and cables
we don't have any of that okay let's
have a look for some batteries
and cables oh there's number two there
two deaths this is weird
i don't understand
oh the pills take the pills
whoa
okay now you know he was being scared
about a bunny well that is a fran bow
bunny
for one
and this is
very creepy
oh a mechanical rabbit it's not very
cute no it's definitely not maybe the
rabbit is angry or hungry
or both hangry hangry is the worst
combination
oh look there's a three there now
and there's an eight
where's all the other numbers then
okay so i've got carrot
nine
there's an eye
pointing this way in the eyes there oh
gosh i'm so confused
can i go have a look at my bunny
oh why did you scare edward anyway
you're very cute
you don't notice it's dressed like you
oh look at this
oh
rude i don't get it i don't get all
these numbers
what is what do they mean
maybe they spell out a word if you put
them all together
so
eena
ina
daz
inades tree
in a des tree oh green thieves
inaudible
in a death tree crat
i don't think this is gonna spell
anything
in a des tree cracked shank
nope
definitely
not
go get a giggit
yes
okay awesome right okay so we've got the
battery
here we go
use the battery in here
now i just need some cables i think
where would i find some cables oh this
one's green now oh nice okay
oh
so i didn't even need the cables or
maybe the cables are needed to open the
door
oh no are these her parents
are you
oh
mommy daddy who did this to you
why are you here please tell me
that's so sad
all right put the pills away now
what okay i'm just turning the teapot
no idea why
oh there's oil here
a water symbol maybe i put
if i use the bucket with it no
ah okay
now i now it makes sense
oh it's missing it
maybe in there
oh she's she doesn't get wet
i thought she would
i don't know
where to put the water
it's locked
i haven't seen i have seen these on
movies
oh gosh oh there's a
here
a reset button
how practical
i have no bloody clue
so what were they saying here
nine
that way
eight that way
hey
this one's
wearing a weird little dress now
i think i need to
remember these cards and which way
they're going
so what about without the pills what
does number one say it doesn't have a
way so maybe it's just the ones with the
pills then
so it goes eight
right
oh gosh i don't know
this is difficult
it's wearing loads of different stuff
this rabbit is so snazzy um
eight
left
all right i need to remember this so
there's one two but i can't get to that
one anyway so go one
three
okay
so eight right
and then eight left
and then
i hope this is right i have no
not a clue
and then six
eight eight six
and then
nine okay i can remember that
eight
eight eight
six nine okay
one two three four five six seven eight
one two three four five six seven eight
one two three four five six
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
no
what
why
see if we can get this bunny out of the
way so we can see what card is behind
him
because
why won't it work it's mechanical
i thought if i could just put the water
over it it would die because it's
mechanical
oh wait of course i have a freaking
carrot and he's a he's a robot
okay eight eight five six nine eight
eight eight five six nine eight eight
five six nine eight five
wait what no ay ay i'm gonna confuse
myself eight two three four five six
seven eight
and then back again
or was it
no the five was number two so then it's
five
one
two three four five
and then back in eight
i think
one two three four five six seven eight
one two three four five six
and then nine's about this way one two
three four five six seven eight nine
yes i didn't actually think that was
gonna work
whoa
let's go down oh we're gonna go into the
other oh no we're not we're in a
different room okay
where are
we this is dark and scary oh god jesus
why did you do that to me
jump scare
happy birthday
what i thought you
kidnapped mr midnight ah
yay
i thought you wanted to kill mr midnight
you lied to me
we lied to you in order to keep your
attention in another direction
i'm very sorry i had to fool you my
friend
we wanted to surprise you my dear friend
coming in cake
all right katie you really surprised me
thank you it would sir
yeah i mean you can't say no to cake can
you the cake looks good the cake is made
of all ingredients you like mr midnight
told me which ones
and we have something very special for
you from all members of the ship what
all the teddy bears
oh and the two dead girls of course that
means all of us naturally born or
handmade beings here you go i hope you
find it educational what is what is it
i love wrapping can i open it now
go ahead open it
it's gonna be something creepy isn't it
are you ready
go on then
oh it's a cutie
i wonder if you can buy them because
they're pretty cute a cat doll oh thank
you so much i love it
it may give your eyes a new perception
you know like the ultra reality
is that what happens when i take the red
pill sir is the ultra reality what i see
well it depends would you like some
explanations
yes
i'm all into other dimensions and stuff
tell me about it
look
what you've seen is a mixture of
different realities and the ultra
reality is like an invisible room where
everything exists at the same time for
example at this exact coordinate of time
and space we're having a birthday party
but in ultra reality other things are
happening all the time yeah those dead
girls are sat right where fran is
sitting
slower faster or just invisible to the
human eye
it's because of time humans can define
past present and future
defining things encapsulates reality it
gives humans a chance to understand
their environment you have a different
perception of the environment
it's not linked to definitions do you
understand what i say
i'm not sure sir i think maybe i feel a
bit dizzy
that may be the shift going up and down
blowing the candles now dear we're about
to reach our destination yeah we're
about to go home did you hear that kitty
yes we are about to arrive ready how
exciting all right here i go
oh that doesn't sound too good
red lights
oh no oh no no no no no no no no
that wasn't good
how did mr mcknight
manage to fork his i don't know oh dear
what's happening are you all right i'm
all right i just hope the [ __ ] won't
break sounds dangerous
bran you have to help i have to drive
the machine again the automatic driver
was destroyed by the camel
there is one alive you have to get rid
of it find it first how do i do that sir
water ah i got water it's so cool
hurry up remember it may be hiding from
your eyes okay
don't worry we got this friend you've
been through so much don't be scared
it's fine
okay
where could it be
let's just keep the pills sights because
he
kind of told us it's going to be in
palestine that's you you're freaky i
don't like it when you're a clown
here it is this must be the kamala
kamalas
there you are you bad thing you
destroying our ship
okay i'll be good
die kamalas die
don't run away where are you going
where is it going
oh this is gross okay so it went up so
i'm guessing it'll be
up the ladder
yeah
don't worry i still oh crud
i don't have any water oh okay wait
haha you went to the wrong place buddy
oh wait there just hold on one second
really is it just gonna stay there and
wait for me to pour it with water
it's not gonna try and hurt me or
anything why are we even destroying it
then
i'm sure it's just a misunderstood
creature really
i think i got rid of the kamala i'm the
best i should get back to edward yeah
let's do it
and let's get out of creepy pill mode
would save we did it the commander's
gone
it's gone yes but it's too late dear i
can't take you home
we're going down
we're going down no no please don't tell
me this it's not fair
i will always take care of you my dear
um
that's pretty cute
that's so cute
and the ship was going down until it
crashed everything was destroyed
the end
but that is a very sad ending it would
tell me another story please
alright this is the story of fran beau
and me
when she promised never to forget me or
about the magic of everything
he i promise it would i'll never forget
you
good
now it's time to sleep
expect me in your dreams my friend
so sh okay i thought i was like that
can't be the end so she never gets home
she lives with the crazy skeleton dude
yeah that makes sense
okay
hey hey hey it's a deer
hey there
hello
oh
it would
it was not here
we're still in the forest reality
we're trying to get to the third reality
we're in the second i think i don't know
guess we're alive we survived the crash
but where's edward
he brought us home we're outside the
town fran i can smell it what their home
are you sure kitty are we already home
i thought you would be happier about it
what is it
it's just that i wonder where edward is
i wish i could say goodbye
maybe you can take the medication to see
him
again kitty but i took all the pills
already you see the bottle is empty
anyway let's go home maybe everybody
will come to see me one day
so they're actually home
oh yeah she did take all the pills
they're all gone
what's in that box that the
philanthropist gave us we're home
oh my goodness this is our street kitty
haze street
yes it is
how the bloody hell
she's actually
it's home of creepy
i like the cactus though
and here we are this looks much more
gray than i remembered
well i hope hard grace will be happy to
see me
hopefully she's there
oh grace hello
maybe she's not home dear do you have
the key to go inside
no i don't have it kitty but i know
there's a hidden key somewhere i just
need to remember where hmm
oh under the plant pots always under the
plant pot uh well i like the cactus oh
okay it's probably no
this one
i took the key
it says i took the key signed fran
but i haven't taken the key and i didn't
write that note
what this is so confusing what should i
do now
yeah it is confusing i have no idea
take a worm
can i climb up oh climb up to the open
window yes
come here kitty you must climb and go
through the window i couldn't find the
key it seems that i already took it
you already took the key but you don't
have it that sounds very strange
yeah it's really strange i only found a
note that i don't remember writing but
now in order to get inside kitty you
must climb
alright wish me luck
you can do it kitty
go
so graceful
mr midnight
oh
fun
i can't believe this you are alive
where were you
don't tell me about please don't take me
back please don't tell me about my
kitties inside and i spent so long
trying to find my kitty dr dean i'm fine
please don't take me back to the asylum
i've been looking for you for a long
time now how did you escape
i escaped through the yellow door why am
i telling him the truth i should be
lying
why are you outside the house
oh i don't have the key but mr midnight
is inside now he climbed and went
through the window of the second floor
sir
mr midnight
isn't that your missing cat
yeah but we found each other in the end
sir
may i ask why you're
here i came to meet miss grace i have
something very important to tell her
i think she's not at home sir
well it may be better this way you'll
have to come with me
no i won't leave my kitty again
let's wait until he opens the door
fran
i don't believe your cat is inside the
house
that's
impossible
i'm telling you the truth he's inside he
will open the door in a minute
stop it fran face reality your cat is
dead you must come with me now
no we just
we just put friend in the house no i
mean mr midnight
no
mr midnight's gonna open the door now
he didn't open the door
don't tell me that mr midnight was never
real
fran
i'm sorry fran
i don't want to hurt or scare you
i'm just worried about mr midnight you
made him leave no you made me leave him
is he really alive
of course he is sir why would i lie
about that
this feels so wrong
you know fran
i was fired from the asylum because i
knew too much
i found things that i do not understand
yet i really thought you were dead
look at these documents
family murder on hay street that's her
that's her family
martin and lucia beau dragon hearts were
found early this week brutally imagined
in their residence on hayes street oh
it's the the
the pentagon the star thing that's what
i used to get back in to the realm the
investigating police officer marco
holman
said
it seems that the bodies were perfectly
sliced which would cause a quick
instantaneous death
also there were no signs of a struggle
in the house so the victims must have
been caught completely by surprise and
were unable to fight back the police
interrogated grace
duggan heart lucy's twin sister but the
police didn't find any useful
information the youngest in the family
fran beau was found in the woods one day
after her parents mother
she froze to death
what
what
dear gladys
let the newspaper know about fran beau
she was found in the woods frozen to
death she ran away from home after
finding about her parents death
beloved friend beau
fran is now free from all pain we hope
you reunite with your family in heaven
that was her aunt grace
but i'm not dead sir this is all lies
well i see that i also found out that
your medicine was switched
you were given a new variant of duotine
when i looked at it in the laboratory
the levels of ect diploma digital were
too high
that can't be good
ectoplameten creates a door between
subconscious and conscious the problem
is if the kilometer is too high the door
will be too wide and that can create a
great confusion in your brain
a great confusion in my brain well i am
a bit confused yes
but that's because of all the new things
that i can see and feel what do you mean
fran
i can see the ultra reality set don't
tell him this you're trying to say that
you're fine to go back home and uh yeah
this is definitely not the way to say
that you're fine but okay
ultra reality that must be the
consequences of duty nothing more
that's not true if i had some more
medicine i could
you're not really
you're kind of proving his point there
you don't need that medicine anymore
besides it's all in your head fran
all on my head you say then i might be
able to control it
i mean
that you're imagining things that's all
oh my god
i didn't expect that
i tried to tell my mother the truth but
farther with her and her as well
oh my gosh this is so creepy i actually
got goosebumps all over my body then
i don't want my father playing game with
his knife again
my arms hurt
oh my god
oh did your father harm you with his
knife doctor
what who told you that
you did or didn't you sir
i i haven't said a thing about it
oh my goodness then it's true
please let's focus but you're not
listening to me sir we need to find out
the truth
i wonder who's behind all of this the
nurses ask what who knows
i do know sir
it's the big black monster remor he's
not going to take you seriously fran
he took my parents and now he hunts me
he wants me dead
oh i wish i stayed in earth esther with
palontras and the great wizards
what are you talking about please fran
i'm serious
i never said goodbye to edward or
polantris and my kitty is all alone
palantras it would please fran
palonchos is the doctor of earth sister
he is a flying creature very fluffy
very fluffy sir
and it is my faithful friend he brought
me home with his machine
it seems you've been living inside a
fairy tale
it wasn't good all the time sir the
twins are gone because of me
i saw myself killing mr midnight and i
saw mother and father too
please don't say that it was fran that
was the killer thus no
the twins wha what twins
the girls that were attached to each
other
attached you say that reminds me of
clara and mia case
two girls in the asylum that claimed to
see a creature named edward or something
it would it would
i think you're understanding sir it's it
would
but what happened to those girls
well we know we saw the little play
about it dr oswald was experimenting it
was dr oswald that did the sewing
ah
mostly to see the reactions the dna but
nothing happened
a few months later they died and their
bodies were thrown into a well
that is awful sir you can't take me back
to the asylum
don't worry i won't
i brought you with me so you can help me
maybe we can find something that will
lead us to those responsible for all
this disgrace
oh thank you doctor
maybe polontis was right about you
you're not a bad doctor you're just an
old man following the rules
following the rules
well
not tonight
badass doctor
gonna help us out but where's mr
midnight is he real please say he's real
this is the cemetery sir what are we
doing
you'll see
follow me
he's going to take us to our grave isn't
he
yeah
this is all
no we're not dead i'm so confused
we can't be
this is your parents resting place
and also yours
why did you bring me here
i'm sorry fran but
things are how they are your parents
were killed
knowing who killed them can help us make
things right
what do you mean by right sir
i mean if we can find the guilty ones we
will have justice
use the law to punish such behaviors and
prevent others from being harmed
i understand sir
and for what do you need my help
to find clues and evidence we need to
open the coffins
all right sir i'll help
maybe the deadly worms came already
who
anyway we have to find shovels to take
i'll go left you can go right
i'll see you in a few minutes right here
yes dr dean
see you soon
okay
oh she's got teddy
so cute
i can't believe
i i'm just so confused she's not
actually dead it's got to be a big
misunderstanding a cover-up i don't know
but then
wouldn't they have noticed this when
they put her on record in the mental
hospital though maybe she is dead
oh it's stuck
this must be a storage room just my luck
can we open it with the knife
no
what about this
what's in here
oh it's a keyhole
hmm
interesting i don't know what to do
why do i still have a crayon surely i
don't actually need a crayon for
anything yeah there's got to be a way to
open it oh maybe we should light the
candles
i don't really know why just because we
can
oh
oh
that's so sweet
i don't think stonewoman is sleepy does
he have something in his car
oh he's got crap oh crowbar to open the
door
what did it not work
hey acorn i haven't seen you around for
a while
shh
you have to keep it down fabio
oh but i'm not fabio i'm fran hello
little punkin
what oh my goodness a giant
oh please don't be scared i won't harm
you
i don't know charles could see us
i think i can see because i have very
big eyes you see
i see i'm sebastian by the way the
tribes collect up
the tribes collected that sounds
exciting
right now we're trying to find some
shiny leather
we're needed for the mating ritual
mating ritual okay
oh that's quite interesting shiny
leather hmm
yes last year we use old human skin but
the deadly worms want it back
so we're looking for something more
synthetic
oh well i hope you can find the leather
hmm sebastian would you do me a favor
it depends on the if on the favor giant
miss oh wait
i get whatever
i was thinking you could open the door
for me from the inside i could do that
but we can help each other out instead
bring me a piece of leather and i'll
open the door all right giant miss
wherever will i find that well i think
his car might have leather actually
okay let me have a little look-see
maybe i can
combine this with this now
hmm
yeah i think i can probably
just wreck his car maybe
take some leather are these leather
seats
yes it's not real leather but
it might work
sorry sir
he's trying to help us and we just wreck
his car
and he won't believe me either but like
i had to give it for the pinecone man
and he will not believe that
whatever it's fine we we know why we're
doing this
i knew that was his voice
wow thank you john miss i tried the pine
xenos will be happy and now i'll open
the door
thanks
sebastian
i'm i'm all right miss yes good thank
you you opened the door
you're welcome janus hey fabio
what are you doing fabio oh i have to go
miss good night and fabio wait for me i
have the leather
funny there's nothing in here
what
okay let's follow fabio
oh he's got it anyway
there you are fran look i found this a
pair of shovels let's dig
so i didn't need to wreck your car after
all
oh my gosh
well now we'll have to come up with
something to open the coffins
they're stuck i had a car by my car but
i couldn't find it
oh i took the crowbar sarah i needed it
to open a door do you want it back
no need fran but you can do the honors
of opening the coffins why would you
allow the little girl who's
the daughter of the parents she's about
to open the coffin of open the coffins
okay whatever you're a responsible adult
obviously let's open our coffin first
the legs are stuck
that's mr bin that's not mister midnight
whoa i'm not in the coffin great but
what is that but that can't be my kitty
because mr midnight is home
okay
at least it's not fran
could have could have been worse oh my
god it's her mum
mother you're so skinny i had a bit too
much i would say
but i guess you would take that as a
compliment wouldn't you
oh my goodness father the deadly worms
took your eyes
i wish you could talk and tell me you
took you away from me
okay
i've opened the coffins
did you see anything that could bring us
closer to the killer
no sir i just feel really bad doing this
seeing my parents like this obviously
also that dead cat is not my cat they're
lying
fran i told you your cat was missing and
maybe this one is actually your cat
it can't be sir i did find my kitty you
have to believe me
take me home i'll show you please
all right fran i'll take you back home
i'll take care of this later i still
need to find some clues
thank you
he's just gonna leave them open like
that
he doesn't seem
he just doesn't seem oh
oh
vanished into the hands of darkness
you have no manners
you have no manners i'm not afraid of
you anymore
i've taken away from you the light
the one you love the one you respect
the one you desire to love you
who's that
mr midnight
who is that
was that that guy
where did our eyes go
huh
what
you broken little girl
the house of madness invites you inside
if you want to find those you love
in a darkness you must wake up
wake up now fran
wake up
chapter five the house of madness
she's in chains
aunt grace why is she chained her up
aunt grace is that you
my darling you finally woke up
you're at home my dear
am i really that's incredible but why am
i trained up i'm so happy to see you
please give me a hug
ah soon my darling
she doesn't want to hug her
and where is mr midnight
your cat
you know he ran away after what he did
what he ran away but what did he do
well your cat killed my sister and your
father
he is a traitor
bugger off mr midnight did no way do
that
that's not true it can't be true he
didn't do it he couldn't cut them off
into tiny bits anyway he's a cat
grace he's a cat i think it's grace
honestly if you ask me i think it's
grace
it doesn't matter if it's true or not in
the end we must have a guilty one right
but you can't blame mr midnight he's my
best friend
but it's easier to blame somebody else
than taking responsibility isn't it
it's definitely grace
i will always take responsibility for my
actions even if they aren't so good
oh what a good girl rest now my darling
you need it
but i'm grace don't leave me
why am i chained to the bed
because your hands do bad things when
they're untied
what are you talking about i'm cuff me
now
i have to go find mr midnight
oh little little shining fran don't you
worry about the lies the secret of the
truth will always die because the evil
will never hide
little little shining fran go to bed and
sleep tight and forget the pain inside
your mind you are selected to suffer to
cry and hate but the darkness wants to
free you from all disgrace sleep tight
my darling fan
what the hell was that about
and the door's gone
don't leave me here aunt grace okay so
this is another reality i'm guessing
because no way doors don't just
disappear like that
why blame mr midnight kitty couldn't
kill my parents his claws are tiny and
soft exactly
i hope he's fine but what should i do
now hmm
tick tock tick tock crazy sound it never
stops
now that i think about it the clock
maker said that time is a layered
reality
maybe there's another version of me in
this room in another time oh oh i'm just
imagining things but if it's true
how can i make contact with her
dr dean said that everything is in my
head
so that's the clark
oh my god what the hell
i didn't think anyone was anything was
gonna happen just by pressing the clock
and the wind took all the magical dust
away
oh hello what are you doing on my bed
are you
sick your bed this is my bed and no i'm
not sick
but you are chained are you a dog wait
do i know you i am you i am an older
version i'm not a dog and yes i'm
chained can you unlock it
oh you're myself you really are
you think so
then this means i managed to enter the
ultra reality
did you meet it already he always talks
about that
yeah i met him already but i haven't
seen him since the crash
you crashed that means you're broken
i'm not broken why'd you say that
think about it the only way to cross
into ultra reality is to break the eyes
to break the ears break the physical
limitation
that sounds extreme
you think
i'm dead
no not at all
they told me that to die is just a
mental state
they
who are they
all the creatures that we can see the
black ones the white ones
do you know why we can see these things
yes
a man called leon came to visit me and
told me everything
oh and can you tell me then why we see
the things we do
what about if i help you unlock the
handcuffs first
then we can talk
good idea
i also need to find mr midnight i think
he's in danger
aunt grace blames him for the death of
our parents who's mr midnight
what
that's our kitty you know our best
friend
i don't have a cat
i guess that's the difference between us
anyway let me see if i can unlock you it
so happens that i'm a key collector well
isn't that convenient
oh maybe she'll have the key for our
little kitty as well go on then go on
then get us the key oh right oh i'm
playing his hair now i'm playing his
little fran ultra reality friend
she's very girly
okay here's the keys
what's this
oh yes it word and the poland
let's see which key
maybe this one i don't know i'm just
gonna try them all
oh that one worked
thank you so much fran he you really
have a lot of keys in there
don't you oh fran before i forget
prolonged has told me if we met someday
i should give this to you here i think
it will help you open something yes open
the box that he gave us this is gonna be
good
ooh
palontras you know him too wow thank you
yeah he also told me that if we met you
would be ready for what's about to come
up
ready
for what
oh no i can't now she's coming be quiet
come on fran
you must see the doctor now
can she not see us
apparently not
we're back in our room now
our little fam we had stuff to talk
about
that nurse is a bad bad nurse
she was the one lying to the newspaper
about me
anyway i must find the monster i'm sure
he took mr midnight but nobody can take
my kitty away from me nobody
what's this on the floor
cool
aliens
um anyway
let's see how we can open this thing
the little golden box was having a hard
time all the screaming and the boogers
boogers were driving me mad
i press it by the ears first twice to
the left and once to the right
twice to the left and once to the right
i rub its only eye two times to see if
it has tears this time i take him once
by the left ear and scream stop whining
you little golden box press your eye
again and open the door what the bloody
hell
let me have a look at the box again
where it's like oh okay this is the ears
left left right
eye
is it left
oh yes yes
okay
my memory is getting better i swear
my memory used to be so bad
okay what do we have here okay we've got
mr midnight key this is good
mabuka mabuka wake up mother mabuka the
horned child is playing with the light
the valaccus angry and shining too
bright mother mabuka wake up wake up and
give up the light the child before the
darkness ends in the hands of the light
mabuka must wake up
let's build the egg a [ __ ] clock a cog
clock
on the back of the giant cat
too strong in the bubbles and too bright
the light she cried
me mabuka the mother of mother of
darkness will open my heart
please take the my little horned evil
child and shut down the lights
what
is happening
okay some weird clock thing cool
and we have the keys so let's combine
this with mr midnight
oh what oh maybe now okay
yes
oh
cool
we found a door
ah
i love this picture he looks so confused
hey it's a pine cone thing
is there something back there i feel the
texture what could it be
uh a key it looks like a key
that's a key
i wonder what for we've already just
used a key
wow she is so girly i didn't realize
is that her sleeping bag
my old school case
oh she had a friend and they both had
little cats
alice from school
like from alice in wonderland because
there's a little bit alice in
wonderland-ish isn't it
let's have a look out the door
this is very alice in wonderlandish
look at that
what the hell
what a big eye what are you looking at
okay so we've got two keys now
so i've got a key here as well let's see
what this one can be used for
no
oh
that did work
this is so weird
intruder infiltrator why would you enter
without presenting yourself i am a
cooler the eye from beyond behold my
beauty
oh i'm sorry what a big eye you are you
must see very well
i see everything
nothing less
oh
everything can you see my cat
your cat how is it possible that you own
a cat are you royal queen princess
no i don't own him but we have a
relationship with friends
friends how lovely but i did see a cat
out here today it was crying for help
from inside a cage the bearer of the
cage entered mukappa's clay underground
he's still down there inside the cage
can you describe the cat you see
big yellow eyes plunked nose it spurs
very dark black is the deepest knight
it's him it's my friend
right
let's go find him
i'm not afraid of her
feel free to take anything you need from
my home you are brave and i respect
bravery very much
thank you akula i'm fine by the way i'll
see you around
sweet let's take this hairbrush
don't know why
to brush some hairs
what happens with polish
i don't know what's happening we're just
walking through paintings this is normal
set button
oh yeah i disconnected the machine
i just try one more door i need to leave
this episode's gone on for for a very
long time but i'm i'm just so
intrigued
thought it would be this one okay
oh another key
i
i don't think that's appropriate mess i
don't know why it's a robot
i'm sorry i'm sorry but i need this key
there are many doors i wish to unlock
tell your friend to be nice and open to
his mouth oh tell your friend for myself
as well he won't he never does besides
his teeth are reinforced
it'd be hard to get that key without his
permission
i'm trying to do like a bony voice it
doesn't work reinforced teeth i see i'll
see what i can do to take the key then
and who are you if i may ask
well i'm fran
nice to meet you fran i'm varieto
welcome to mcboober's
i haven't been here before
don't don't judge me for not knowing
tell me who muker is instead
okay mabuka is the mother of the
darkness oh so she's the one who wants
that little
box thing made or whatever it was
the darkest darkness the obscurity the
end of light
my book was the mother of all creatures
from the fifth reality
what am i from the fifth reality i
thought remore was the king there
ah remor the terrible black the son of
darkness
nobody likes him too much
you should go now i've said enough
all right i'll be back later anyway i
must get your friend's key
is this it was clothing but where is he
maybe they're all kind of elated and
there's like a good side of the family
and a bad side of the family
inside the little house
hey i'm here
does the sound of my heart disturb you
it can stop all of a sudden and that
would be the end
i i don't like thinking about my heart's
beat i i just want the soap
soap
are you having trouble with hygiene
oh yes terrible problems with hygiene i
smell like my flesh was all rotten
inside
but that sounds delicious
i don't think that would be a problem
maybe for you just let me have the soap
for a little while
no right then take it it's all yours
thanks
be careful with the hijackers they love
children that smell like soul
they eat their baby bodies and keep
their heads their beautiful baby faces
it sounds terrible
you're not one
you are definitely an odd one
oh do i still have my bucket thing no oh
i can use this though
okay so i have uh
some water i don't know why
all right that is enough for this
episode i think we're nearing the end
now i'm getting so confused i thought we
were gonna go home i got all excited but
no we're still back in some creepy lands
and this one
yeah it's a lot creepier than arthaster
was this is actually pretty freaky but
pretty cool because it's kind of like
alice in wonderland anyway give this a
thumbs up if you enjoyed cause it helps
me know what you like and stuff and also
have a lovely day or even bye